my name's Samuel Leeds were here at the  zero program we've actually found and  sold five deals today we've been out  with you them we found them and we've  sold them which means that we've made  more than ten thousand pounds between us  today and these guys are now celebrating  they're talking about their successes  and they're brainstorming ideas because  we want to double that tomorrow have you  do some business excellent good man  we've also generated some no money down  deals there's one girl actually the guy  right there you can see him but his name  said he is now living rent-free forever  no money down and I've just today in  front of everybody found five no money  down leaves we're going to be following  up tomorrow this is just incredible if  you think financial freedom through  property is art then you really need to  get down and experience some of this  stuff for yourself thank you